hi everybody i'm jonathan shunts and  today I have another tactical challenge  for you so when you see the image on  your screen go ahead pause your video  and we'll see if you can solve it in  this position it is white to move the  solution to today's puzzle is Queen  takes c5 a very dramatic move and let's  see why this is the right answer if you  take back with the rook and if you don't  take back well then you're just down a  piece now White has rook to a8 you have  to block with your Queen after we take  your queen and you take back hopefully  you see the final move you need to find  Knight to e6 working the king and rook  so after the King moves to any square  you take the rook and white wins thank  you for watching this tactical challenge  if you guys liked it hit like share  subscribe and we'll see you next week  we're not a technical challenge  [Music]